– Hast du kurz Zeit?
– Ja.
– Hey!
Es gibt Neuigkeiten!
Wir haben einen Investor!
– Yes!
– Was? Einfach so?
– Nicht ganz.
Er gibt uns vier Wochen Zeit.
Das heißt, wir müssen den Lieferservice
in einem Monat starten.
– In einem Monat?
Wozu soll das denn gut sein?
– Na ja, er will sehen, dass wir es
wirklich ernst meinen.
– Wir meinen es ernst! Deshalb brauchen
wir auch mehr Zeit zum Planen und so.
Das schaffen wir nie im Leben
in vier Wochen!
– Wozu brauchen wir am meisten Zeit?
– Na ja, wir brauchen bestimmt viel Zeit
zum Ausbauen der Küche.
Das dauert mindestens drei bis vier
Wochen – wenn es gut läuft.
– Außerdem brauchen wir noch ... ein paar
Wochen, um neues Personal einzustellen.
Das geht auch nicht so einfach. Die müssen
ja auch noch eingearbeitet werden.
– Und du? Was musst du noch machen?
– Ich erstelle die App und die Webseite
und überarbeite den Businessplan.
Aber das geht relativ schnell.
– Das wird stressig. Ich weiß nicht,
ob wir das schaffen.
Die Arbeit im Restaurant ist ja auch noch
da. Wir können ja nicht einfach schließen.
– Können wir den Termin nicht verschieben?
– Nein.
Und es gibt noch eine Bedingung …